Hello everyone and Merry Christmas everyone.
I didn't really have the time to prepare a game for you like I usually do
But I decided since it is Christmas. I will at least share one a nice puzzle with you.
I don't remember the exact time I saw this puzzle, but I remember this one instance
I was probably at a tournament somewhere with Yun Almighty
And we were driving from the tournament or to the tournament, can't really remember
And I asked him to solve this puzzle, but I asked him to do it blindfolded
I only said the position to him
I told him the king is there, a bishop is there, pawns are there, rook is there,
And he had to solve it, and it took him like a couple of minutes
But in the end he did solve the position and we had a really good laugh
So this is one of the.... one of the puzzles that I really find interesting and its really
It's a...., if you've never seen it. It's a pretty amazing puzzle and you'll really feel a lot of joy
After you solve it. So this is the puzzle I do invite everyone to try and solve it
Give it a couple of seconds, pause the video and really try to solve this. It's white to win
Really, try to win it any way you can
there is there's actually a very nice win but
Anyway, you can win it. It's it's perfectly fine
So pause the video and try to do it for yourself, I will give it a couple of seconds as usual
Okay, you know just in case you want to decide what we want to pause the video
For those of you who who were able to solve this I congratulate you,
Very nice job.......
It's, it's quite the puzzle. I always enjoy when I see this puzzle and for those of you
Who maybe weren't able to do it or maybe didn't have enough time to study it for yourselves,
the idea is...
You have to play rook to h6 and this is the only move that actually wins the game
Now as you probably, if you try to solve it you probably notice that black can't really move the bishop.
Now after rook to h6 if you move the bishop to pretty much any square
White will simply play rook captures on h7 and this checkmate, on a7 sorry...and in this is checkmate.
and if you try any other move for example
If you don't move the bishop
Let's just bring back the pawn here
after rook to h6
You might want to try and capture the rook that's probably the only other reasonable choice after you capture the rook white plays
b7 and this is checkmate now, so this is this is the solution to the puzzle
I really hope most of you were able to solve it, if you were able to solve it
You know be sincere write in the comments. I was able to solve it or hashtag solved or anything
I just wanted to share this one with you guys. Hope you all have a very
Joyful and Merry Christmas and as of tomorrow
I will see you very soon as usual so as usual you can check to my previous videos here
Thank you all for watching and I would like to thank Kent Stefan, Eric Wilkinson
Jackson Novotny, John Anthony turbos and Matthew Dickinson for a contribution to my channel, thanks a lot. I really appreciate it
Thank y'all for watching once again, and I will see you soon with a lot of videos as usual. Thank y'all!